Argh, stupid small phone, stupid
small buttons, stupid big fingers.
Pete, why are developers
trying to torture me?
>> Well, they're not really
trying to torture you.
>> Well, it really seems like
it when the buttons are so
small that they barely take
up a pixel on the screen.
>> Yeah, it's true.
Tap targets or anything that a user
might touch, tap, click, or try and
do input on, need to be big enough and
easy to hit.
And spaced so that you're not going to
accidentally hit two at the same time.
With a mouse, users can
be perfectly accurate.
Our fingers, on the other hand, and
sorry about that pun, it was bad.
But our fingers are about
ten millimeters wide, or
half an inch, which works out
to be about 40 CSS pixels.
>> Oh, okay.
So buttons should be at
least 40 by 40 pixels.
Well, instead of doing 40 by 40,
you should make them 48 pixels
wide by 48 pixels tall.
That makes sure that there's enough
room between the elements, for
those of us who have fat fingers and
fat thumbs.
Yeah.
It's okay to make some tap
targets a little bit smaller.
But make sure there's at least 40 pixels
of room between any of your top targets,
to make sure that users
don't hit two buttons or
two elements at the same time, or
miss it completely.